في هذه النافذه للتحليل العسكري لمجريات
حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه وفيها
نستضيف المحلل العسكري اللواء فايز
الدويري ونتابع اخر تطورات المشهد ميدانيا
على الخريطه التفاعليه مع محمود الكن تفضل
محمود نعم ليلى الخريطه هذه تشير الى
كيفيه سير المعارك والتوغل الاسرائيليه
وكيف تكتمل هذه الصوره على كامل قطاع غزه
في المناطق الصفراء نشاهد توغل اسرائيلي ا
في كامل القطاع شمالا وجنوبا دعونا نبدا
من المنطقه الشماليه هنا في القطاع حيث
كنا نتابع التصريحات الاسرائيليه عن
ادعاءات بكشف انفاق هنا في مناطق في وسط
غزه نتحدث عن ميدان فلسطين وحي الرمال في
هذه المناطق تحديدا هنا كان يقول المتحدث
باسم جيش الاحتلال بانه تم الكشف عن
الانفاق ايضا الجي الجيش الاسرائيلي كان
قد ذكر بانه
ا سيطر ب في هذه النقطه على جباليا طبعا
ليس كامل جباليا لكن بهذا ان صحت هذه
الادعاءات فانه سيكون بذلك تمكن من وصل
هذه القوات من الموجوده في شرق جباريا
ومخيم جباريا وغرب مخيم جباليه وبالتالي
في محاوله لفصل بيت لاهيه هنا لكن نتذكر
دوما اننا نتحدث عن توغلات وليس سيطره هذه
الادعاءات كان قد ذكرها جيش الاحتلال منذ
ثلاثه اسابيع بانه تمكن من السيطره
على جباليا ولكن اليوم يعيد مثل هذا
الاعلان او يوم امس بالاصح اعلى اعاد هذا
الاعلان جيش الاحتلال ما زال ايضا
يحاول الدفع في المناطق الشرقيه من السياج
بهذا الاتجاه وبالتالي في محاوله على ما
تبدو متطابقه مع التصريحات السياسيه التي
كانت قد ذكرت سابقا
بانه بان اسرائيل قد تاخذ او تك تتواجد في
جزء شرق في الجزء الشرقي غرب السياج شرق
السياج نتحدث
عن توغل بحدود كيلومتر و 200 متر تقريبا
على كامل القطاع في محاوله لتكوين ما يسمى
بمنطقه عازله لكن هل يمكن لهذا ان
ينجح نتذكر دوما هنا ان منطقه
الشجاعيه يحاول جيش الاحتلال التوغل فيها
لكنه يواجه مقاومه ضاريه في هذه المنطقه
كانت كتائب القسام قد اعلنت عن استهداف
عشرات الدبابات عشرات المدرعات في كامل
قطاع غزه وايضا تدور معارك عنيفه جدا في
جباليا هنا جيش الاحتلال كذلك كان يقوم
بعمليات القصف لكن المقاومه تزال قويه هنا
ام
طبعا كلما تقترب هذا يقترب هذا اللون
الاصفر من المناطق المدنيه ذات الكثافه
الاعلى تزداد حده القتال دعونا نشاهد ايضا
الاستراتيجيه في هذه المنطقه في وسط
القطاع سنشاهد بان الجيش الاسرائيلي ايضا
حاول التوغل هنا في شرق البريج
والمغازي بالتالي تبدو هذه وكانها ترجمه
للتصريحات السياسيه الضغط ما زال ايضا
مستمرا هنا في الجنوب اذا ما شاهدنا
الجنوب زياده في العمليات العسكريه زياده
في القصف هنا في بني سيله ستشاهدون اللون
الاصفر كذلك هو من الشمال ومن الجنوب
وبالتالي القوات الاسرائيليه ما تسال
تحاول الضغط عندما توغلت من شارع كيسوفيم
الجراره محور صلاح الدين واتجهت غربا
باتجاه منطقه المطاحن ومدينه حمد ايضا ام
التوغل من هذا من الجهه الجنوبيه في
محاوله للتطويع لكن بحسب المصادر المفتوحه
لا يوجد تطويق كامل حتى هذه اللحظه اذا كل
هذه العمليات تتكامل سويه ليله لنرى
الصوره الاكبر والتحليل معكما ومع اللواء
فايز دويري شكرا جزيلا لك
محمود اذا في اليوم ال 75 للحرب
الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه قالت كتائب
القسام ان مقاتليها فجروا فتحه نفق شرق
خانيونس فور تقدم قوه من الاحتلال نحوها
ووقع افرادها بين قتيل وجريح كما استهدفت
دبابه ميركافا بقذيفه الياسين 105 شرق
مدينه خان يونس جنوب قطاع غزه اذا هذه اذا
من المعلومات التي نتابعها وكما شاهدنا
اللواء فايز دويري مع محمود قبل قليل في
اليوم ال
75 لبدء الحرب في اليوم ال 51 لبدء الحرب
البريه هذه المشاهد للمواقع الصفراء
لانتشار الجيش الاسرائيلي ما الذي يمكن
قوله عنها
يعني مبدئيا خلال ال 36 ساعه
الماضيه بصوره مؤكده ازدادت وتيره
العمليات العسكريه من حيث القصف ودفع قوات
جديده
ومحاولات الدخول في عمق المناطق المبنيه
لماذا لانه هناك مسار موازي المفاوضات
وبالتالي هذا امر طبيعي عندما يكون هناك
مفاوضات من اجل وقف اطلاق نار كل جانب في
الحرب التقليديه يسعى لتسجيل نقاط اضافيه
تساعده في الضغط على الطرف الاخر لكن في
الحرب غير المتناظره هنا يكون دور المهاجم
هو صاحب المباداه يحاول ان يفرض وقائع
ميدانيه جديده فيما الجانب الاخر يحاول ان
يحول دون تحقيق تلك المكاسب لهذا السبب
نجد انه في ال 36 ساعه الماضيه حدث تغيرات
على الخارطه حدث خاصه في منطقه منطقه
جباليا ومخيم جباليا و ال الكثافه الناريه
والاحزمه الناريه التي استخدمها في هذه
المنطقه في هذا في خلال 36 ساعه الماضيه
امر لا خارج الت نطاق التص ط محاولات يعني
مستميته لدخول هذا المخيم هو محاول الان
هو مخيم جباليا هو اتى من الجانب الشمالي
من مخيم جباليا على اساس يلتقي مع القوات
اللي تقع ل الشمال من الفالوجه من اجل
محاصره مدينه بيت لاهيه ويقول انه تم
محاصرتها حتى اللحظه التي نتحدث فيها لا
توجد معلومات مؤكده من الجانب المقاومه
بانه تم قطع هذه الطريق وتم عزل مدينه بيت
لاهيه اذا نحن نتحدث عن مئات من الامتار
لا تزال تفصل ما بين القوات في الجهه
الشرقيه والقوات في الجهه الغربيه ولا
افاجئ ان يتم عزل هذه المنطقه لماذا لانه
دفع بقوات بحجم كبير جدا خوض معركه
تصادميه من قبل قوات القسام في امكاناتها
من حيث اسلحه قصيره المدى هي ستكون معركه
خاسره للمدافع لذا ليدخل ليقول انني طوقت
ويعطيني مسا مساحه استطيع اداره معركتي من
المسافه الصفريه اشار محمود بصوره واضحه
الى محاوله السيطره على المنطقه المحاذيه
الزراعيه المحاذيه للسياج على طول 42 م
وهو من خلال حتى ال 48 ساعه الماضيه بدا
في هذا العمل حقق انجازات وان كان العمق
لا يتجاوز ال 1200 متر في بعض المناطق
ولكنه يسعى لتوصيل هذه المناطق مع بعضها
البعض قد ينجح في منطقه وادي غزه ومنطقه
شرق دير البلح الى الوصول الى حدود خان
يونس لكن ستبقى المنطقه في شرق خان يونس
بن سيلا ستبقى نوعا ما عصيه قد يطور
عملياته اكثر من ذلك يذهب الى جنوب لماذا
ستبقى هذه المنطقه تحديدا عص لانه القتال
فيها شديد وطبيعه القوات الموجوده فيها
لواء غزه وبقيه كتائب النخبه من الفصائل
المقاومه الاخرى الجهاد الاسلامي وغيرها
لكنه قد يفتح الان جبهه جديده الى الجنوب
من الفخاري ليحاول ان يفصل مدينه
رفح الغزيه عن مدينه رفح المصريه وبالتالي
يكون قد حقق عمليه العزل من الجنوب ومن
الشرق يهدف الى السيطره على هذا السياج
هذا الشريط على الحدود كامله البحر هو
مسيطر عليه الخط الشمالي الذراع الشمالي
مسيطر عليه يحاول هذا التوصيل ويحاول
سيحاول لاحقا ان يحقق التواصل مع من من
الزاويه الجنوبيه الشرقيه باتجاه مدينه
رفح وصولا الى شارع الرشيد ويكون قد حقق
نقطه قويه يتوقع من خلالها انه يفرض
ارادته وشروطه في المفاوضات والان الحديث
عن ارسال لواء وكاتبات هندسيه للكشف عن
انفاق ما مدى نجاح الجانب الاسرائيلي في
الكشف عن الانفاق التي فعلا يمكن ان تشكل
فارق هذا يعتمد على طبيعه شبكه الانفاق
وهي مجهول للجميع يعني لا لا يوجد معلومات
تفصيليه عنها ولم يتم تسريب كل ما نتحدث
به هو بعد تحليلي استنادا الى تصريحات
الان الحديث انه يوجد هناك 1300 نفق بصوره
عامه 500 ك من الانفاق الكل يتحدث مع غزه
مدينه الانفاق الجانب الاسرائيلي يتحدث ان
الانفاق غزه اكبر من انفاق مترو لندن كلها
معلومات عامه ولكن هذه بما انها شبكه
عنكبوتيه هذه الشبكه ستكون ضمن قواطع
معينه اتصالها واسع لكن في الانتقال من
منطقه لاخرى ستكون ضمن قنوات محدده حتى
كما حدث في هذا اليوم التصريحات ب انه في
منطقه الرمال او في منطقه ساحه فلسطين تم
تحديد فتحات انفاق هذه اذا ما اذا ما كانت
موصوله بصوره مفتوحه مع شبكه الانفاق
ستقود الى معرفه بقيه الانفاق في تلك
المنطقه مما يحدد من عمليات ال القوات
قدره القوات المدافعه
على فتحه نفق موجوده الان بالقرب من
الساحه هذه الساحه التي هذا ما تحدث به
وعرض الصوره على العموم كتائب القسام اذا
تقول ان مقاتليها فجروا فتحه نفق شرق خان
يونس فور تقدم قوه من الاحتلال نحوها وقد
وقع افرادها بين قتيل وجريح نتابع هذه
الصور
اذا اذا يعني هذه الصور
التي نشاهدها تباعا
يعني هذه ليست اول صور نش يعني يمكن هذه
المحاوله الس رقم سته او سبعه يتم تفجير
فتحات الانفاق في بعض الحالات يتم تفجيرها
باليات او بتفجيرها بالافراد في بعض
الحالات تم التفجير داخل النفق اذا هي
عمليات ما يسمى تفخيخ الانفاق وهذه عمليه
معروفه بالنسبه للقسام ولجا اليها اكثر من
مره وتم قتل اكثر من جندي وضابط في هذه
العمليات طبعا صور محاكاه ما نشاهده الان
نعم ولكن لكن هذه عندما نتحدث عن هذه
الحديث الان في شرق خانيونس المنطقه فيها
مسافات بينيه قد يكون نفقا داخل احد
المناطق المبنيه او قد يكون ضمن المناطق
المفتوحه ما اهميه ودلاله ان يعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي الان انه يرسل لواء ويرسل
كتائب هندسيه هذا يعني ان ان العقب ال
كاداء امامه في في فرض ارادته والحديث عن
القضاء على حماس يجب ان يكشف اي شبكه
الانفاق لانه حماس اين هي موجوده ليست على
على سطح الارض هي موجوده في شبكه الانفاق
وبالتالي هو الان اولويته من وجهه النظر
العسكريه بالاضافه الى التمدد والدخول هو
كشف ماهيه وحقيقه شبكه الانفاق عله من
خلالها اذا استطاع ان ان يسبر غورها
ويستطيع الوصول الى اجزاء كبيره منها
ستساعده في تحقيق هدف العسكري كما يرى وهو
في هذا هذه الاهداف ومحاوله تحقيقها ايضا
تحت ضغوط يعني ماذا تقول عن استراتيجيه
الجيش الاسرائيلي في هذه الفتره من حيث
الاعلان من حيث اللعب على الجانب النفسي
يقول ان قاده حماس موجودين في هذه الانفاق
بينما الشعب الغزي يعاني كل هذه الامور
اذا ربطناها ببعض هل هناك اي تقدير ل يعني
تغيير ما في الاستراتيجيه اعتقد يعني رد
على هذه تصريحات احد كتاب
ومذيعين هو مذيع ويعمل كاتب في صحيفتها
اريتس ووصف احاديث المتحدث حجاري الناطق
باسم جيش الاحتلال وصفه بعبارات لا استطيع
ان ان استخدمها لانها خارج اطار الادب
وبالتالي ساقول بان كاتب هارتس رد
عليه اذا سنكتفي بهذا ولكن لن نكتفي من
المشاهد اللي ايضا تظهر اقتحام مجاهدي
القسام مع اليات وجنود العدو في محاور
مدينه خانيونس لنتابع هذه الصور
اذا اذا هذه الصور نشاهدها معك لواء فايز
وفقط نذكر ايضا المشاهدين بدلالتها وما
الذي هذه عمليات القنص لدبابات جيش
الاحتلال وهذه تصور لنا الحقيقه كامله
تجسد الواقع امامنا شاهده لاحظ هذه
الدبابه وبجانبها الجرافه الان لننتظر
ماذا سيجري اين اين ذهب السهم يبدو باتجاه
الجارفه وسنرى
النتيجه هذا الفرق بين افلام القسا
الفيديوهات التي عرضها القسام والفيديوهات
التي يعرضها جيش الاسرائيل جيش الاحتلال
القسام يعرض الصوره كامله من كافه ابعادها
كما يقال فيما الجانب الاسرائيلي يظهر
جانب واحد فقط وهو جانب اداء قوات
الاحتلال دون وجود عدو
مقابل ومره اخرى يعني في الفيديوهات التي
اظهرها الجيش الاسرائيلي ايضا يظهر عنصر
وكانه بحاجه لكي يظهر نجاحات لمشاهده في
الداخل ولكن في النهايه يعني من المنظور
العسكري كما تقول سياده اللواء لا يبدو
انها تحقق الهدف لانها تفتقر للعنصر الاخر
المق هو الان يعرض جانب واحد من معادله لا
يعرض الصوره كامله يعرض نصف الحقيقه يبين
الجيش الاسرائيلي لكن اي محلل او متابع او
لديه خبره في عسكري يرى ان كان هذا عرض
صور اللي في ميدان التدريب ولانه الودو
وهمي وليس حقيقي فكان ما يرضه جيش
الاحتلال من فيديوهات انها عمليات تدريب
ضد عدو وهمي فيما القسام يعرض لنا الحقائق
مصوره وبالتالي اي مقارنه بين الجانبين
يكشف الحقيقه ان القسام يجسد الواقع فيما
الجانب الاخر يعرض صور يرسلها الى الداخل
الاسرائيلي لانه يتوقع ان فيديوهات القسام
لا تص ويعرض الصور لمجرد عرض الصور وليس
لاار اي شيء حقيقي لاحظ التركيز على على
النفق الرئيسي زاروا وزير الدفاع وتحدثوا
عن انجاز استراتيجي ظهر القسام وقال وصلت
متاخرا المهمه انجزت في هذا اليوم عرض صور
فتحات الانفاق هو يقول بانها في ساحه
فلسطين ويقول بانها في التلال لكن حقيقه
هو لم يعرض صوره
للمنطقه انا كالحظ هو عرض مباني وعرض
مباني هل المبنى موجود في ساحه فلسطين ام
موجود في بيت لاهيه ام في بيت حنون الصوره
لا تعطيني انطباع لكن لاحظ هنا هذا هذه
الصوره تجسد الواقع اشكرك لواء فايز دويري
شكرا جزيلا لك